[Music]
we have a very important mission for
tonight we must use stealth and cunning
to infiltrate the human world and
retrieve go-karts
okay Batman what I'm just trying to Hype
you guys up let's go from Seth Rogen
comes a movie that crushes for
absolutely every age
amazing insane all right tell me more
effortlessly cooled and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this year
[Music]
that seems very dangerous see danger for
breakfast actually I eat pizza with bits
of waffles on it
with the funniest cast ever assembled
surprise
[Applause]
oh man you can't stop us
we're the only ones who can do this
I'm awesome we're brothers we fight
together we're just getting started
[Music]
yeah she sounded like a leader I do oh I
do oh I sound like such a leader and you
ruined it
Turtles
remember don't let any human see you
happy theaters August 2nd get your
tickets now
[Music]